[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul and it's time to rick and
roll as we get into rick and morty
season six the first episode is here and
throughout this video we'll be going
through the easter eggs plot ending and
what we thought of the entry now in case
you can't remember the ending of season
5 then the first part of the video is
i've made it just for you you son of a
[__] i'm in in the finale we watched as
an elderly morty return to rick who'd
been out acting as a samurai with his
two crows it was revealed he just used a
formula to age himself up and the pair
traveled to the citadel in order to get
him back to normal here we discovered
that evil morty had now become the
president and he was attempting to get
to the central finite curve we
discovered that the curve was a walled
off section of the multiverse which
separated all of the universes where
rick isn't the smartest man alive from
all those where he is he'd hacked
everyone's portal guns which explains
how they couldn't get back and had also
rerouted all of the operation phoenix
clones in order to use them to power
this citadel so that he could travel
into the curve evil morty just wanted to
live in the universe without wreck and
the season ended with him breaking
through and now possessing a golden
portal gun we watched as he disappeared
we also learned more details on the
backstory of rick first he's that in
rickshank redemption after beth and
diane were murdered by a version of
himself from the multiverse he perfected
his portal gun and slowly started
hunting himself after realizing all this
killing was pointless he and the other
ricks came together to build a citadel
and rick venture to a universe where
beth was still alive now he and morty
managed to escape the citadel with some
other mortys and they drifted off into
space anyway that should have you fully
caught up and if you enjoy the video
please hit the thumbs up button and make
sure you subscribe to the channel for
breakdowns on the series every single
week without the way thanks for clicking
this now let's get into the video
[Music]
we start off with the citadel adrift in
space in the aftermath of evil muddy's
plan in a call back to the beginning of
avengers end game we hear rick giving a
speech that echoes tony starks this
includes how there's no power of food
and it leads to the pair both looking
gorn like how tony did in that scene we
discovered that some mortys turned feral
and that the extra ones either went like
that or they were torn apart by the
feral ones they end up lying down
together and similar to captain marvel's
arrival a beam of light comes in and we
see space beth show up this isn't the
only marvel reference either and when
summer goes down into the basement of
the garage we can catch several
callbacks to their characters this
includes a cyclops visor thor's hammer
and also magneto's helmet some might
also get to wolverine claws though they
are more in line with x-23s rather than
logan's
bit of an actually there which i
apologize for but just just pointing out
the easter eggs and being thorough with
them the season comes with a couple of
new scenes that appear in the intro this
includes a giant flying squirrel
swooping down to get rick and who i
believe is summer we then cut to
victorian london and see rick and morty
dressed as sherlock holmes and watson
respectively they're meeting with jack
the ripper which we can tell by the
bloody knife in his hands and also one
of his victims in the corner his then a
wrecked parade with a giant floating
building of the character being pulled
along by the public here we can catch
zimmer and you might also notice there's
beth as well as space bet beside her you
can also see morty being yanked along in
the background and this is a nice little
detail on how rick's always pulling him
along and getting him in trouble is that
a reach probably now we then see jerry
in a mech suit getting shot at by lasers
and i've even seen theories that this
might be a universe in which jerry is
rick which i think would be hilarious
the final shot ends with morty getting
dumped into a frying pan and you butter
hope that he gets out of there alive
this is of course probably reffing on
the saying out of the frying pan and
into the fire and i really hope that
these shots are from some episodes in
the season now the episode is called
celerix which is based on the george
clooney movie solaris this involves
character chris calvin arriving on a
space station above the planet solaris
and over the course of the film we
watched as memories of the crew
manifested in physical form which
included his deceased wife not only does
the entry start in space some of that
film but it also deals with their loved
ones being replaced as we learn what
really happened to rick c137 and the
other smith sanchez family members they
return to earth with her and are greeted
by beth who brings out sandwiches
however due to it being too much at once
they bring out digestibot which i feel
is kind of riffing on the robot from
rocky iv but that might be a reach
i'm just gonna risk it rick accidentally
resets portal travelers instead of
portal guns and we realize that he morty
and jerry aren't originally from the
universe that they reside in now both
beth and space bear to remain behind in
this reality due to the fact that there
was cloning involved with a pair and
they weren't from alternate universes
there's lots of similarities to the
shell sliders which involve people going
across the multiverse into slightly
different universes where things were
either changed massively or only very
slightly it turns out that the jerry who
we've been with isn't the original and
we meet hermit jerry who was the one
from the first season this happened
during the events of rick potion 9 aka
the sixth episode of season 1. the jerry
that we've been following on the most
part is from morty knight run which was
the second episode of season 2. this
episode itself is brought up in the
entry and we're told that this is where
the two gerries were swapped out with
one another beth asks where their rick
and morty are and summer says that
they're buried in the backyard which too
is a callback to rickpotion9 this
episode is later referenced towards the
end of the entry only it involves all
the family burying their counterparts
instead of just the two the three end up
having an adventure together whilst rick
goes home to see a bomb blast on the
floor that was shown in the flashback of
the season 5 finale here he sees a
hologram of the rick murderer that was
revealed in the episode and we learned
that this happened because rick turned
down the opportunity to join them rick
speaks to diane who we learn is actually
the voice of his garage bot who's
programmed to always be just one room
away huge head out to the website
tvtropes.org for pointing out that this
has the same voice as rick's garage ai
showing how he still has some piece of
air left behind in his tech tv tropes
also coined the phrase hermit jerry
which i like and this entry is filled
with very sad characters like him and
diane but she then brings up summer but
judah beth being dead she'd never been
born in this universe hence why the
machine doesn't know who she is now in
this reality rick wasn't able to move on
from the death of his family and thus he
created a time loop for everyone to live
in so he could constantly relive that
tragic day however he forgot to allow
people's bodies to stay young and thus
they've been aging up whilst their mind
is still stuck in that moment in a
similar scene to the ending of season 5
he travels into a rift and we get
visuals that pull from not only that but
also the ending of 2001 a space odyssey
morty returns to his own universe to
find it looking like the last of us and
here we see the jaws booth that summer
operated in potion number nine the only
person that appears to be left alive is
hermit jerry who we end up learning a
lot about
both beth and summer died and we end up
getting two batman references this comes
in the form of the dark knight returns
which he says that he read after things
went to hell and it's basically about an
elderly batman it's dark and gritty like
him and our other batman reference comes
when morty explains that batman doesn't
abandon his allies he however abandoned
his real family and it all comes a
crumbling down now we also get a
reference to the game downbeat which
morty finds under the bed this is a game
that's popped up in the series before
with rick not being able to understand
the rules so they never finished it like
what morty says here homie jerry ends up
leaving and morty promises to find him a
new reality though he prefers to live in
this one alone beth and summer ended up
dying after the events of rick shank
redemption due to them freezing and the
guys just found a place where he can be
free guess because everyone's not making
fun of him here now he has given some
vindication as moody is even betrayed by
his ride showing how hermit jerry might
be right summer and co drop a pin so
rick can travel home but first he has to
grab morty however diane bock gives him
a heads up that there might be another
rick here as morty's real grandfather
wasn't around huge hit out stallio 1 30
on reddit for coming up with a brilliant
theory and he talked about how the
character could be the prime rick i
really enjoyed reading this and it also
takes us into
aaliyah says that because this wreck is
the wreck that killed our rick's
original family that this is likely the
dominant one that first discovered
portal tech it's possible that he then
traveled through the multiverse in order
to give this tech to other ricks so that
they could take over
rick we know rejected him so this might
be the case that he forced him down a
path in which he'd create the attack by
killing his family this rick's sole gain
is to become the most powerful force in
the multiverse and he'll make the other
ricks join him whether they like it or
not rick 317 is the real deal and he's
truly set out to rule over all he loves
doing over-the-top elaborate plans like
building stuff in minecraft on a private
server and he is the most rickiest rix
of the rix and when rick and morty find
his hideout they catch an apparent naked
clone of him he ties with them by saying
this could be the real hymn or that it
could just be a duplicate the post
credit scene of the episode reveals that
it's actually him as we catch his clone
tube and also see him putting his
clothes on he says he did just a [__]
with a guy which was of course rick c137
wait not not c137 look i don't know
either way he ends up killing him at
jerry after the character states
fatality which is a reference to mortal
kombat he offers the villain team up
which is a trope in movies and tv shows
where the villains join forces captain
obviously there for that so just
if if you're editing this stich just
show a clip of venom and sandman in
spider-man 3 or something make it look
good now we have just had evil morty so
they're going to the next level with it
and making it so that evil rick is gonna
be the big bad of this season and this
also confirms that morty is prime morty
and that he's the grandson of the one
who started this entire thing it's a
really nice twist and that's the end of
it
[Music]
here it goes wild and he gets pulled in
a prime rix game in which he turns him
and makes him run the gauntlet however
muddy pulls him out of it by saying he
doesn't really know his true grandfather
and that the replacement one is the one
he really cares about he brings up the
phrase rick and morty a hundred years
and this calls back to the pilot in
which rick goes off on one and says rick
and morty forever and forever 100 years
freaking mortysome things me and rick
and morty running around and rick and
morty time and back with beth and co we
see as some arrests use them out of a
space alien's stomach and they had a
nice little arc about also appreciating
what they had rick and morty return and
we see jerry is actually off in the
universe where he's spoken to worse than
the main one he lives in they return
home and after a great bloody joke we
see that season 2 jerry has also been
swapped over due to not being from his
original universe he's still stuck in
the mind state of when he and beth
almost got divorced and he ends up
releasing mr frundles this highly
infectious creature turns everything
that it bites into it and thus it
quickly swarms the planet after
multiplying at an incredibly fast rate
this turns the earth into a giant mr
frondles echoing images of ego the
living planet from marvel which i should
have really put up top but here we are
and they also travel to an alternate
universe where parmesan is pronounced
palmision and they bury the bodies rick
claims that they all died of natural
causes but looking at the blast marks on
the floor
it doesn't really seem that way like at
all in the kitchen beth apologizes for
going dance moms with summer and space
beth agrees to come around from time to
time in the garden morty ponders where
the prime rick might come back for him
but rick says that he doesn't care about
anything this is why he was happy to
murder an alternate version of his
daughter and child because he's seen
everything to the point that he doesn't
care about anything anymore he's a great
new villain for the show and that closes
out the episode in a big way as with my
thoughts on it i did enjoy it and this
lore heavy entry was a great way to
start season six last time there was a
lot of talk about how so many episodes
weren't really connected to the cannon
and they even made a big point of it
with the finale yeah though i think this
is a good place to start off with this
getting things that tie back heavily to
the law the series is now six seasons
deep and i love the way that we're
finally getting answers to stuff having
us focus on the riku started all as well
could lead to this being one of the best
seasons yet and i am excited to see
where we go with it and of course love
to hear your thoughts on the episode so
make sure you comment below and let me
know we are in a competition right now
and giving away three copies of top gun
maverick on the 15th of september and
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episode we pick the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one on screen right
now so if that's you then message me on
twitter heavy spoilers you want emails
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of house of the dragon
which will be linked on screen right now
episode 3 has just released it's a
bloody banger so definitely go head over
there right after this by the way thanks
for sticking through the video i've been
poor i'll see you on the next one take
care peace